to do I'm from Cuba by the way it said
there is no NFL in Cuba I came to this
country 20 years ago and so far so good
so how that they our league works so you
pick your teams that's basically how it
how it works you put you pick your teams
that you want as a winner you rang them
that's the way that you put if you
happen to hit the winner you can wait
those points if Philadelphia for
instance nothing wing that's this week
those 15 points is down the toilet they
don't bother the little matter for you
so every every week that's the idea and
I mean I decided to two-year solution
maybe there is a better way to this like
let's think about this be smart about
this because we want its armies or
family running the link so and the other
side is always not only for the sake of
like getting some points but hey we beat
you because we get to meet those guys
all the time so on the berry world is
interesting the belly wall already
provides your view of the world so the
spreads you think about it this press up
make us give you is like the benchmark
as to what the world thinks about the
games a simple stripe would be to run
the choices each week by this spread so
you take your winners you take the
spread you rank it from the higher
spiritual / spread and you pick the
winners away there's other ways to rank
the big day the winners by a means of
like windows records basically the
opponent's strength their home in a way
the vision on division games whatever
Peter came decides to say all these are
the winners I don't know you pick some
pundit doesn't matter but ideally the
point spread to encapsulate all this
information now the question is how good
is this press strategy well in 2008 the
simplest rallying would have lost by six
points so it's a song aids you can see
em it was the winner and this price for
it would have been like running second
place we all we consider the winners if
you finish on the three instead
finishing in the money finishing the
money means the top three on average
this press project would have won in
about half the years maybe less than
that it's important remember remember
that Israeli require requires no
thinking you take their spread you
started your pedic teams let's go there
is no thinking involved you have to
halo with the winner who is in Europe
doesn't matter pick the winners are
straight from the spread for instance
this is for the last scene starring h
the winning score is this is core
picking the spread this have been the
score so two years have been the winner
the less the other years this get up in
primm close to the top you usually use i
will show you the state of the game
today the first place the difference in
the first place second place around 15
points so anything below 15 points will
get you in the morning and that's good
be good enough for you so the question
is now can we do better ah can we win
every year that will trying to prove so
wrote a cover or alright so what's the
idea the idea would be um we try to
figure out a quick method so we were on
the crunch time last summer so what we
do they still something better say we
can use simple regression right so you
take a line and there from there we do
some little prediction forget there're
let's go for it we were about it we're
thinking maybe maybe not as well it's
going to be further let's try a logistic
regression so as you know logistic
regression is used to classify data into
in two or more different groups and for
simple cases that boundary is very easy
to the limit so you can delimit the
boundaries very straightforward and
sometimes there is no need for a line
it's nonsense to be a completely linear
boundary it could be a very very big
curve on the boundary the whole idea
this is easy for us since we're using a
logistic regression function for a
classifier is very suppose to give you
the probability when we run the teams
and that probability we can use the
probability us will be our probability
of picking up winners and in our pool
since the goalies picked a binary elko
so so basically wings are lost losses it
makes sense to use this specific
algorithm since I get a priority red of
the bat all right the most simple one
will be just get a set of features that
sort of characteristics that we want to
fit the machine learning algorithms and
get an output that says basically if you
want to be a winner or not that's pretty
much so we get
we got together so let's think about
which features we're going to use so we
need to determine versus all relevant
features and we also we need to think
about room what they call they
classifier it means what vices what
exactly am I going to be predicted for
that we're gonna use Python we're gonna
have a little Python not to show you we
use a cycler as our main library to work
so we brought this little program that
will make gonna make available the rest
of the world today then we have a little
notebook this is very unsophisticated a
little notebook that picks the games for
us and then we did right way some back
testing then certain we are we also a
big cycling fans and we have three
studies we have our Merck quinoline
during if you know bicycles or cycling
races you bro know who those guys are we
figure out so which is the best strategy
we tried three different usually see
regression three different outcomes to
what to pick versa you want to take over
this yeah thanks so the spread
strategy is the one that we talked about
where you just you don't use your brain
and you just pick according to the
spreads the three will go into the
details of the machine learning
algorithm but basically the first
strategy the merc strategy is where you
still pick the favored team all at all
times but you ranked by the probability
that the machine learning algorithm
picks spits out the second case would be
you pick the predicted team because if
the probability that the team is going
to win is less than point five that
actually means that you're predicting
that the underdog is now going to win so
this is like one strategy to start
picking the underdog instead of the
favorite team at all times and then you
still have to decide how you're going to
rank this and so the third strategy is
to not only pick the team that the
learning algorithm picks out but also to
rank by you know like let's say a team
was ranked as zero percent probability
of winning that means that the underdog
has one hundred percent chance of
winning in which case you should
probably rank them the highest 16
instead of the lowest which is like one
so you know we in reality the third
strategy makes the most sense like it
fits the physical description of the
problem but in the end we still wanted
to win the league and we wanted to do
what seemed like the most reasonable
thing to do and it turns out that the
you know strategy has like a higher
higher average you know performance as
well as a smaller standard deviation so
we decided to go with the second
strategy to see how we would do so will
will go into like how we're doing this
season and so let me switch to the
notebook now see if I can find that guy
do I make this guy green button Duggan
will screen that good
Larry all right good enough all right so
here's our ipython notebook where we
kind of go through the code here our
source of historical data is actually
very simple a lot of people have asked
like why we didn't incorporate other
data like whether at time of game
temperature you know whether it's on
grass or turf or you know whether Green
Bay is playing inside or outside all of
these things so we didn't go into any of
that stuff it's a very simple data set
it's just the historical outcomes of the
games and what the spread was going into
the game um and you know you can there's
a lot of places for it this is the place
where we got the data so you know the
beginning of the Python notebook is
pretty standard stuff you're you know
setting up your paths you're telling it
where to find you know various you know
like the lookup data we need to know you
know which what the season outcomes were
we need to know what divisions the
different teams are even little things
like you know names of the teams and
stuff like that you know so here's like
a little snippet of the teens so here's
where we start getting into the
nitty-gritty in terms of what are we
using to actually do our classification
right so our features are the record of
the favorite team the record of the
underdog last so where it says previous
favored in previous underdog that's last
season's records that might be useful
when it's early in the season nobody's
played each other but you know probably
last year's Super Bowl winner has a
better chance of winning then you know a
team that was Owen 16 last year and then
as the season progresses you would
imagine that the previous seasons record
becomes less and less important and the
current season record becomes amor amor
amor game week is like which week are we
in the season it turns out will show
this a little bit later this uh I
thought this was going to be a very
useful feature because you know let's
say you're want to know that's a hundred
percent winning percentage or let's say
your tenant oh that's also a hundred
percent winning percentage and it seems
like a tenant Oh should be more
meaningful so I thought the game week
would be like this you know factor or
feature in the algorithm that would sort
of highlight the fact that teams are you
know good teams were doing better
but it turns out that the actual score
that he gives this coefficient is you
know not very good or close to zero so
it seems to have marginal value but
maybe it's because some of the
information that it in Capulet
encapsulate seeeeee might already be
sort of incorporated into some of the
other factors the absolute line is just
the absolute value of the spread because
we're already the way that the it's
figured out you know we don't have to
use the minus or plus sign because it's
already picking a favorite or underdog
team and won the division game is you
know the teams are broken up into three
divisions within two leagues because you
know teams like Pittsburgh and you know
Cleveland they're always playing each
other they have a much more familiarity
with playing each other there's like
some sort of division rivalry animosity
hatred whatever you want to call it it
turns out I mean from my personal
experience as years of watching football
is that you know even bad teams tend to
do well at home versus their division
opponents so we put that in as a feature
and whether you know and this is the
favorite home game is just really just
true false because we want to know when
we go to classify what we're actually
classifying which is did the favorite
team win we just want to put that in
there as like your they favored to win
at home generally speaking we trained on
three years of data and we test on the
following year so in this case we're
trying to test to see how we're going to
do on 2014 is a current year so on any
given week we need to train on the last
three years of data and you know spit
out predictions for the current leader
so here we what we have created a
created like a rapper this created a
classifier object where you give it the
training data you give it the test data
you run the this is the part that where
the site gets learn package comes in
this is the actual object for the
classifier within the site gets packaged
there's lots of different classifiers
you could use this is the one that we
started with the logistic regression but
we'll show you shortly how to use
different ones we've made our code like
modular to the extent where all you have
to do is pass in a different classifier
and rerun the prediction and the rank
it should you know give you the right
answers and so this is the kind of a
thing we get like you get a training
accuracy on the training data you get a
prediction accuracy on the thing data
and this shows you so right now like I
was saying is that the current the line
score which is the spread method is
giving us is winning the league so it's
zero points ahead of the winner which is
good for us because we're gonna make
some money unfortunately the the he
knows so the these are in kind of more
obscure terminology but the strategy
that we pick the eno strategy that we
showed before unfortunately this year is
not performing very well so it's down 41
points it's a bit like trading on Wall
Street you back test your algorithms you
think you're going to make lots of money
you turn on the machine and of course
you start losing money immediately right
but we are speaking of yeah he decided
to only any circumstance we are going to
change the algorithm to build on you all
right but what we have done is it gives
us an opportunity to like test different
classifiers to test different methods to
see like what we could be doing better
and try to use this as like a research
you know problem so this is what we get
on weekly basis one of the you know the
functions that the object has is like
please predict you know what teams are
going to win this week so this is
actually for the current week you know
it's gave a ninety-two percent
probability of Indianapolis winning
because the line is 14 on them the
Philadelphia their line is 11 and so you
can see more or less the predict
probability is sort of similar to the
line but there are some deviations in
this case you know San Francisco is
favored by 8.5 but you know the Chiefs
are actually ranked higher than that at
a seven you know align the prediction
probability is higher than their spread
would otherwise indicated you follow me
that you've lost last Thursday so writer
so this was a bad pic and then at the
edge you go down to the bottom any team
that is below fifty percent it will pick
the underdog to win and I think in fact
clean when last I checked is winning but
it's a
beelo little probability bet down there
it's only two points so it's not really
changing anything one way or the other
and so this is how we like on a weekly
basis like come up with what we're going
to do right right so then let me just go
down so this is a interesting graph that
we have here this is just to get a sense
of like remember we showed the decision
boundary before like between the
classifying winners and losers this is
just to give you a sense that it's not
this is kind of like a multi-dimensional
problem where it's not so easy to
visualize the winners you know only the
spread is only right like about
sixty-three percent of the time and this
is showing that if you plotted the
record of the favored team versus a
record of the underdog team you know on
average the favorite team seems to win
but there are plenty of situations where
you know underdogs with like pretty low
records bead favorites you know there's
a bunch of Reds in there which are Reds
meaning like wins by the underdog team
Blues meaning wins by the favorite team
and so you can see it's like a kind of a
mix-up problem which is why you might
want to go down this route of using the
machine learning to fig you know
uncouple it for you this is basically
how this is right now this is like we
have to keep a key prey collateral for
tonight's game so this is hamad I mean
so this is ameena this is me fortunate
for choice game thatís by five that
decision is no one in the paper this
body pics and i also i am using the
strip society is basically using the
algorithm study so i use the DOM is
funny and dallas is a fairy and thus i
mean you can see also going to see you
can see what people think about it they
interesting things that if you think
that the spread is like the benchmark
here today up to now they spread mean
that um s-sorry is spinning every time
like price data than everyone else is
pretty much a better answer I was
curiously you is there sort of a kind of
like diminishing returns efficient
markets or a thing where you can say
maybe so this slope we thought about it
we have this argument with we think
about the spread it's really a Hydra
benchmark like by this up if I hope we
come from finance all we have friends on
projects and while we proof is like
everybody says my name is my x pic by
the index on liquid it we still think
that they might be a way to do it ah but
we need to find extra information I want
the features of a one to add that we
haven't had it yet it's a more technical
um offenses our defenses business and
statistics out there called bee boa know
how you know how how many are you guys
quit now focus of all this this guy
profootballtalk.com I finna set aside us
awkward business that is called vimeo
english has been very very accurate for
the last like six years i would want to
incorporate video a offensive offensive
give you a young woman as official
pictures and we think that that might
give you some sort of leg up that could
be the case I still I can't array with
you because the spread is like being
everybody been just to be on the top no
so so we decided to basically because
we're using we're using training data up
to last year we don't use new training
data that's the sign that's exactly we
go because it means that if I retooling
algorithm if I which is true I can
optimize it algorithm and we thought
about it but it means that I'm
incorporating information from this year
that I don't want to basically I don't
want to pollute my thinking sort of
thing so I have all the information last
year and let's work with that and we
might win by using the future but we
have a good idea for what happened in
the past and the reason we wanted to go
that way
yes sir yes yes is the absolute line so
it doesn't so we found out one of the
things that dominates is like previous
record like the third reproduce like for
instance one thing that we saw at the
beginning of this year it gets bit
alkaline in the first game everybody
have the opinion that video gets are not
a very good team the second game was the
yes again Green Bay and they'll go pick
the gates and they was picked a textile
right at the top like worry oh this is
great and the kids got destroyed so so
it doesn't matter the face that we know
we know that there are problems in the
algorithm but we weren't trying to see
how the whole thing works that was the
walter goals no no they spread it says
absolute line number five that's the
point spread is the absolute value of
the point spread no we are covering the
queen of spread know with the spread so
we're picking game alright so you only
pick the winners it doesn't matter of
the sprint OC on yes we are we are not
sure we are we are we have to think
about that we all this a lot of
questions that we are still absolved I
will need to just cover it to use the
final score that's a good question
that's it that's that's definitely
equation you're correct and we were
thinking because the what I'm gonna say
so this is right maybe we'll do
something about it path we chose that
basically technically asleep or mine and
then we realize we look at the waiter
the game week has almost no affected so
why is that because maybe exploring the
fear factor and that's exactly the
reason you're totally correct yes sir
ah we thought about incorporating
something I'm going last that is coming
so while the thing that we have problems
with is at the very beginning of the
season we only the only thing the mark
to us is like previous year record and
that momentum will be great and that's
if we built that gets from the gets game
that would have taken care of it i'm at
the idea but we didn't yes sir yes no
because there is a favorite this and
where this one is luis at favorite favor
a regular under load yes take the sign
we take this a delight for the same
favor that's what we do it yes sir
you're right you will get other metrics
like you know maybe one that year
because he really gave three games at 16
points and maybe write the other side
I'd really had a large American points
was ahead right yeah so that seemed like
the simplest place to start because the
point was to try to win the game but
maybe like you look at the accuracy of
the test set you know as if it's picking
69 percent right yeah yeah that's a good
suggestion yeah the good thing is we
like found like it's really good to talk
about the stuff because like everybody
watches everybody has a thought and you
know everybody who's a fan has like some
like intuition about it and so we're
trying to figure out like what are the
things to put in that which parts of
your intuition are worth putting in and
which parts are just feel just like I
don't like the Steelers or I don't like
their quarterback you know
no yes in the region free because that's
brie actually into a site to report he
said real and we always want the great
so we'll have a way to [ __ ] me but we'll
just assume that like the spread is like
incorporating right cuz let's say you
know the Patriots are gonna play whoever
that's bad and then Tom Brady like
injures his knee of course the spread
should go down to incorporate that
usually Chris not as much harder what
one thing that uh basically yes I never
seen so that's what exact thats my goal
so I was when we started we were trying
to look for what people have done to
pick games with the massive google
searches we only saw only one other and
person is speaking about this thing like
in Google there is no not really like
nobody's ever liked try this a list or
it's not published whether there are so
successful that I want to polish I don't
know so I never seen anyone buy one
guide i use basically based theory two
big games and he was very successful
with family so this is I've been working
for us and we have 50 people we have a
list the spread method so we have two
studies going we think that if we get
way more people we are bound to lose
because when you have way more people
it's like the whole you put a typewriter
to monkey the monkey will type chess
pure same area somebody's going to be
able to buy pure luck but it's still
having the spread as a hedge it's our
it's our goal that's what you're doing
so right thing that we have a we're out
of time all right thank you guys